لقد شهدنا نموًا كبيرًا للغاية في
أسعار العقارات السكنية في
الرياض مدعومًا بالطلب المحلي من
الشباب السعودي الذين يحاولون
الانتقال من التأجير إلى التملك
وكذلك مشتري المنازل الثانية الذين
يتطلعون إلى شراء الطلب في الرياض
قوي بشكل استثنائي في  اللحظة
لأن الحكومة تضع
الرياض كمركز تجاري جديد
للمملكة ، هذا هو المكان الذي نرى فيه الجزء الأكبر من
النشاط الاقتصادي ، وهذا هو المكان الذي نرى فيه
معظم الشركات الجديدة التي تتطلع إلى تأسيس
نفسها ، وهذا هو المكان الذي نرى فيه
الكثير من السعوديين يهاجرون إليه.  الرياض من
مدن أخرى في جميع أنحاء المملكة ، لذا فإن ما
رأيناه في الوقت الحالي هو ضغط تصاعدي كبير
على الأسعار في الواقع في الوقت الحالي ،
ارتفعت أسعار الشقق بنسبة 32
في المائة في الأشهر الـ 12 الماضية ،
ارتفعت أسعار الفلل بنسبة 21 في
الأشهر الـ 12 الماضية  ولكن إذا نظرنا إلى ما
يحدث لقيم
المعاملات وأحجام المعاملات ، فإنها في الواقع قد
انخفضت ، لذا في الأشهر الستة الأولى من هذا
العام ، فإن العدد الإجمالي  إذا انخفضت مبيعات المنازل في
الرياض بنسبة 60 في المائة مقارنةً
بالعام الماضي بأكمله ، فقد لا يكون من العدل
مقارنة ستة أشهر إلى 12 شهرًا ، لكننا
سنحتاج إلى النصف الثاني المزدحم جدًا من
العام لمواكبة عدد الصفقات التي
حصلنا عليها.  في العام الماضي ، لذا فإن هذا
يشير بقوة إلينا أن هناك
بعض تحديات القدرة على تحمل التكاليف التي
بدأت في الظهور في
السوق وهذا بسبب
ارتفاع الأسعار وأسعار العقارات ،
لذلك نتوقع أن يهدأ هذا الاتجاه
للمضي قدمًا ،
هذا هو سؤال المليار الحقيقي ، أعني
أه تعلم أن ما فعلناه هو أننا
ألقينا نظرة على نسب القدرة على تحمل التكاليف ، لذا
ننظر إلى دخل الأسرة إلى
أسعار المساكن بحيث تصبح الأمور جاهزة لشراء
شقة في الرياض تحتاجها  ثلاثة
أو أربعة أضعاف دخلك السنوي لشراء
فيلا ، فأنت بحاجة إلى حوالي ثمانية أضعاف
دخلك السنوي في جدة ، أي حوالي 13
ضعف دخلك السنوي لشراء فيلا على
مستوى العالم ، وعادة ما يكون المتوسط ​​المقبول لما
يعتبر معقولاً هو أربعة أطنان.  o
ستة أضعاف دخلك ، لذا فنحن أعلى من
تلك المستويات بالنسبة للفيلات ، فنحن نقترب من هذا
المستوى بالنسبة للشقق ، وإذا نظرنا إلى
الذروة الأخيرة للسوق ،
فقد شهد هذا السوق دورتين ، فنحن الآن في الدورة
الثانية ، وهي الذروة الأخيرة  كانت نسب
الشقق حوالي أربعة قبل أن يبلغ
السوق ذروته ، لذا فإن البيانات
في الوقت الحالي تشير إلى أننا قد
نكون على وشك ذروة جديدة أو على
الأقل هضبة جديدة حيث
استقرت الأسعار لفترة ولكن ما هي
الأساسيات  من حيث العرض مقابل
الطلب ، لا يزال لدينا نقص في
العرض عندما يتعلق الأمر بالقطاع السكني
والرياض خاصة
بالنظر إلى الخطط التي تمتلكها المدينة من حيث
النمو السكاني ، أعني بالتأكيد البحث
عن الرياض فنحن نجلس حاليًا عند
حوالي سبعة  ونصف مليون شخص بحلول
عام 2030 ، من المتوقع أن يصل عددهم إلى 17 مليونًا
، ونتوقع تسليم حوالي 200000
وحدة سكنية جديدة في
ذلك الوقت ، وهذا يكفي
للنمو السكاني المتوقع ، ليس الأمر كذلك ،
ولكن الأساسيات  قضية tal التي لدينا الآن تتعلق بالقدرة
على تحمل التكاليف إذا
لم يكن بمقدور الأشخاص تحمل هذا
الانتقال من التأجير إلى الامتلاك ،
فسوف يستأجرون لفترة أطول أو سينظرون
في خيارات أخرى في السعودية وقد
أجرينا بعض التحليلات حول هذا الأمر.  نظرنا
في ميزانيات المشتري لأول مرة ، لذا فإن
متوسط ​​مشتريك لأول مرة في السعودية
سينفق ما بين 750.000 إلى حوالي 2 مليون
على منزلهم الأول إذا كنت تبحث
عن شقة جيدة النوعية من غرفتي نوم
في الرياض ، فإن تكلفتها تزيد عن 750.000.  إذا
كنت تبحث عن فيلا بثلاث
أو أربع غرف نوم ذات نوعية جيدة ، فستكلف أكثر
من 2 مليون ، لذلك من الواضح أن هناك
عدم تطابق بين توقعات المشتري لأول مرة
والمنتج المتاح